[Música]
podría asegurar que la mayoría de los
que estamos aquí tenemos una relación
interpersonal efectiva y si no es
efectiva al menos tenemos una relación
interpersonal en nuestra vida
normalmente esto solemos asociarlo con
alguna persona que tenemos un vínculo
que puede ser por afinidad es decir mi
amigo mi amiga el novio la novia la
familia los compañeros de clase los
compañeros de trabajo entre otras sin
embargo cuántas veces solemos asociar
este término de relaciones
interpersonales con la relación que hay
entre un docente y un alumno si uno a
uno
pensarlo suena bastante sencillo además
de relacionarse el maestro con el alumno
que tanto es pero si lo pensamos un
poquito más y entramos un poco más en
contexto tal vez esta idea nos pueda
sonar un tanto descabellada vamos a
hacer un pequeño ejercicio les voy a
pedir que cierren sus ojos y se imaginen
un aula un aula llena de alumnos puede
ser de cualquier nivel de educación
que sea una escuela pública
y comiencen a imaginar cómo era esa ola
a lo mejor tiene un pizarrón de gis si
les tocó pizarrón de gis tal vez ya
tiene un pizarrón blanco recuerden las
ventanas recuerden la ventilación el
docente
muy bien ahora sus ojos
cuántos alumnos había en el aula no me
contestó
antes de yo iniciar con esta charla hice
preguntas a varias personas mientras
practicaba yo les decía este mismo
ejercicio y algunos me dijeron sabes que
es que cuando tú me empezaste a decir
aspectos del aula perdí a los alumnos de
vista pero como 30 35 y hubo otros que
cuando les hice la pregunta bueno
cuántos alumnos salían del aula la
respuesta era 30 ok
gracias muchas veces
entonces me di cuenta de la realidad que
tenemos actualmente en el salón hay
alrededor de entre 30 a 35 40
estudiantes por aula es decir está
saturado ahora sí pensemos en el gran
reto de la relación interpersonal entre
docente y alumno
sin duda alguna esto es básico para la
educación y eso es nada más pensar en un
maestro en primaria que tiene 40
chaparritos ahí pero a ver pensemos en
la educación secundaria donde el maestro
no solo tiene un grupo tal vez 2
o cuatro de diferentes grados diferentes
edades
ahora cuando avanzamos un poco más en
media superior este número suele
aumentar y las diferencias son todavía
más grandes
todos los alumnos que están en esos
salones son diferentes
todos son diferentes actualmente se ha
llenado lamentablemente al docente de un
montón de miedos porque porque pareciera
que aquel alumno que visualmente me doy
cuenta que tiene un rasgo físico
diferente al del resto es una barrera
para yo poder enseñar o también que
aquel alumno que viene diagnosticado con
alguna discapacidad síndrome de
necesidad educativa especial es una
barrera
o incluso aquel que no habla la lengua
materna que la mayoría es más que a
nivel cultural es diferente a los demás
esos son una barrera para la enseñanza y
el aprendizaje pero si nos damos cuenta
de que todos los alumnos son diferentes
entonces estamos hablando de que esta
universidad áulica es una barrera y
todos los alumnos son una barrera
es ahí donde tiene que entrar la
conciencia de poder y tener que conocer
a nuestros alumnos para que esta
diversidad no sea un obstáculo sino que
se convierta en una herramienta que le
permita al docente poder diversificar su
metodología sus técnicas su evaluación
sus estrategias entre otras
que es difícil sí sí lo es
solo pensar que tenemos componentes
subjetivos
influyen en esta relación como la
familia la economía los problemas
personales la diferencia de edad entre
el docente y el alumno la diferencia en
madurez la diferencia del razonamiento
estos componentes que nos conforman como
personas son capas adheridas a la
personalidad de cada uno que hacen
complicadas estas relaciones aún más
porque cuando yo les platiqué al inicio
les dije que por afinidad ustedes tenían
una relación interpersonal efectiva con
aquel que ustedes pueden llevarse bien
sin embargo en esta ocasión los alumnos
no tienen la oportunidad de elegir a su
docente y el docente tampoco tiene la
oportunidad de elegir a sus alumnos es
aquí donde nos enfrentamos a otro reto y
es un reto real porque normalmente
cuando uno se enfrenta a la vida laboral
un poco tiene esa oportunidad de elegir
con quién va a trabajar y con quién no
por lo tanto debemos entender la
importancia que tiene conocer a los
alumnos porque no solo uno es distinto
ni los que más resaltan no pueden ser
etiquetados sino que todos son distintos
y eso me he dado cuenta porque mi
carrera me ha permitido verlo la
educación especial me ha permitido
observar únicamente con la observación
una herramienta bastante útil que no
solo uno necesita apoyo sino todos y
estoy seguro que todos los que estamos
aquí hemos tenido una necesidad
educativa en algún momento de nuestra
vida sin importar que no tenga un
síndrome sin importar que no tenga una
discapacidad
he tenido una necesidad de mi vida
y lo digo desde ejemplo de manera
personal es algo que puedo mencionar
porque pasé toda mi primaria siendo un
monitor de aquellos alumnos que no
terminaban sus trabajos a tiempo y en
forma es decir yo era la alumna que
terminaba mis trabajos y luego debía
ayudarles para mí no era funcional
porque mis maestros se fijaron en que yo
podía terminar pero no se fijaron de que
a mí no me era sencillo ser socio
afectiva con un compañero y ayudarle
hay una gran diferencia eso quiere decir
que mis maestros no me conocían y para
mí se volvió más complicado y no me
gustaba no me gustaba terminar a tiempo
porque debía ayudar
y aunque es una forma y una metodología
que se emplea hoy en día sin duda alguna
es algo que debe emplearse de manera
efectiva porque porque todos son
diferentes
el docente además no solo puede
enfocarse en esta parte cognitiva por
qué pues porque está interactuando con
una persona con un humano esto quiere
decir que además el docente debe tomar
en cuenta lo afectivo y lo emocional así
es se debe crear un ambiente de
confianza en donde el alumno se sienta
motivado se sienta capaz se sienta
escuchado y con toda la posibilidad de
poder opinar sin que sea juzgado o
criticado o esté expuesto a alguna burla
es decir cuando el alumno se siente de
esta manera está aprendiendo mejor
lo que pasa es que cuando el alumno al
mismo tiempo que interactúa con el
contenido y aparte está liberando
emociones positivas la huella del
aprendizaje queda aún más profunda
entonces crear ambientes favorables para
el aprendizaje
obviamente favorece a los alumnos
acá está que debemos cuidar una línea
bastante delgada debemos darnos cuenta
de que los problemas del alumno no son
mis problemas de que puedo conocerle más
no debo implicarme hasta donde el
maestro debe conocer para poder enseñar
para saber cómo y qué es lo que debe
aprender su alumno
y no sólo se trata de conocerlos a ellos
como docentes es nuestra responsabilidad
también permitir que los alumnos nos
conozcan a nosotros
y es sencillo ni siquiera se necesita
ser maestro para saber que alguien se
encuentra decaído hoy o que si no
desayuno anda caminando con sin ganas
es bien fácil identificarlo
nos damos cuenta con el lenguaje
corporal y preguntamos oye qué te pasa
aquí
y lo sabemos ahora imagínense un maestro
que diariamente dé a sus alumnos y sabe
que algo diferente está pasando en ellos
diariamente los puede observar y no está
de más poder preguntarles cómo te
sientes desayunaste hoy si no porque
tienes ayunas te porque estas conductas
que estás teniendo a lo mejor se echó un
shot de azúcar en la mañana hijo le
llegan más despierto que nadie oa lo
mejor ni siquiera tiene para desayunar
en su casa entonces no puedes poner
atención
son preguntas simples pero son preguntas
que nos llevan al conocimiento y yo
estoy convencida de que si el maestro
conoce a sus alumnos lo que deben
aprender y cómo deben aprender lo vamos
a obtener mejores resultados educativos
gracias
[Aplausos]